[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a 5 minutos con la
administración de medicamentos y
alimentos de estados unidos otorgó
aprobación total a la vacuna contra el
cob y 19 las farmacéuticas pfizer bayón
takes para su uso en mayores de 16 años
es la primera y la única vacuna contra
el virus totalmente aprobada en el país
pues hasta ahora el resto de los
fármacos cuentan con la aprobación de
emergencia para analizar este tema está
con nosotros el doctor oscar franco
epidemiólogo director del instituto de
medicina social y preventiva de la
universidad de berna académico de
harvard y de la universidad erasmo de
rotterdam y por supuesto asesor
científico de france24 doctor los
saludos gracias por estar con nosotros
nuevamente le pregunto qué significa
esta aprobación para facer
son excelentes noticias en varios
frentes no solamente para países que
país equivalente que son las empresas
que trabajan en este producto ven a su
producto aprobado completamente y ser el
primero pues esto marca un hito en el
mercado sino también tiene repercusiones
para los otros que están produciendo
vacunas que pueden ver que este esto se
sienta un precedente y tercero para la
lucha contra la pandemia porque hay una
gran un sector de la población que
permanecía escéptico acerca de la
seguridad de este producto y con estas
noticias ojalá podamos ayudar a
convencer a estas personas de que este
es un medicamento es una vacuna que
realmente asegure que es eficaz y que
vale la pena utilizarla ahora actor qué
diferencia hay entre la aprobación de
emergencia y la aprobación completa de
una vacuna
las aprobaciones requieren un gran
número de evidencia de detalles que se
tienen que evaluar exhaustivamente por
expertos se mira muy al detalle toda la
evidencia que existe y la emergencia se
hace con una cantidad de datos que no es
suficiente para la aprobación total pero
que se aprueba simplemente porque
estamos en una emergencia como el caso
de la pandemia la aprobación total lo
que quiere decir es que tiene ya este
medicamento todos los requisitos como
todos los demás medicamentos que estamos
recibiendo en el mercado eso quiere
decir que esta vacuna realmente es un
medicamento que es eficaz y que es
seguro que son los principales aspectos
que se miran en darle la aprobación
completa ahora ante este presente se
esperan nuevas aprobaciones de otras
vacunas
si es posible que nosotros las otras
empresas no solamente las que están
produciendo vacunas con la misma
tecnología que estaba con énfasis el que
es la vacuna de adn a qué hablamos
es posible que estas vacunas que ya
habían recibido una aprobación de
emergencia con esta nueva aprobación
total es posible que las próximas
semanas vean una aprobación total
también una aprobación completa y esto
ayudaría a tener más productos que sean
confirmados como efectivos y seguros en
el mercado ahora esta aprobación tiene
algún impacto en el debate sobre la
tercera dosis que por cierto ya habíamos
hablado en un programa anterior
si ya está teniendo un impacto en
términos de regulaciones porque ya vemos
por ejemplo el
departamento de estado de los eeuu y
algunos colegios que van a empezar ahora
que ya se tiene la aprobación completa
se van a tener requisitos mucho más
estrictos para poder ir al trabajo o
para poder atender a ciertas funciones o
eventos se va a requerir la aprobación y
el certificado de vacunación y es
posible que en un futuro también se
aplique este tipo de requisitos para la
tercera dosis entonces lo que estamos
viendo es que va a haber un número de
repercusiones en las próximas semanas
que aún están por desarrollarse pero yo
creo que tendrán un impacto también en
la tercera dosis y cuando se aplicará
esa tercera dosis doctor y con esta
aprobación completa países de adelante
de ferrera con la competencia con
nosotras farmacéuticas
sí ya ya venía adelante ya no solamente
en eeuu ya hay 200 millones de vacunas
aplicadas con facer y alrededor del
mundo muchas más y ahora con esta
aprobación lo que va a hacer es que
confirma este este medicamento este
producto de países bien tec como un
producto seguro eficaz y que tiene una
superioridad respecto a los otros en
términos por lo menos de tiempo porque
fue la primera que se aprobó entonces lo
más seguro es que veamos muchas más
vacunas de facer aplicadas en un futuro
lo que también tendrá implicaciones para
su producción las empresas van a tener
que poder satisfacer es además esa
demanda que se va a aumentar no
solamente en los eeuu porque estas
aprobaciones lo más seguro es que se
continúen en otras partes del mundo pues
doctor gracias por su tiempo y por
supuesto por estar aquí con nosotros en
cinco minutos con de francia 24 ustedes
también continúen con nosotros porque
hay mucho más para ver aquí en nuestro
canal
[Música]